[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mike florio pro football talk live
co-host joining us on the program mike
good morning how are you
i'm doing great dan how are you i'm
doing okay until i just got the word
carson palmer wants his heisman back
you can have mine
yeah
yeah you got one yeah no no i don't have
anything i don't have anything that you
would ever want so you don't have to
worry about that do you have any
trophies on your mantle no none
i i have
none none
i could say something smart or funny or
cute i have none i have nothing i'm an
embarrassment to everyone all right uh
why is this report on desean watson feel
a little
more real than what we heard maybe a
couple of weeks ago well we're getting
closer and closer to the deadline for
2021 and look back in late august early
september
this was pointing toward a transit
action between the texans and the
dolphins the problem is the dolphins
refused to blink when it comes to what
the texans want and the texans refused
to blink when it comes to what the
dolphins wanted to give so it fell apart
but it continues to linger it's going to
happen either after the season or it's
going to happen between now and november
2 at 4 pm eastern i think what happened
yesterday was an effort by the texans
to get the word out to anyone else who
may want to come to the table you know a
few weeks ago the panthers may have not
been interested now maybe they are a few
weeks ago the broncos wouldn't have been
interested now maybe they are let's see
will the eagles come to the table let's
see because if others come to the table
price goes up and it may get stephen
ross who badly wants to make watson a
miami dolphin finally say to the texans
fine we'll give you what you want the
texans don't want to relent because they
don't look at it as a one or a two year
trade they look at it as a 10-year
transaction so you shouldn't worry about
what you give us now whether or not he's
going to be available in the short term
he's going to be your quarterback for 10
years so give us what we want because
you're getting a franchise quarterback
that's going to change potentially the
fortune of your team but if you're the
dolphins what do you need to know before
you make this deal and what can you know
before this
you know the the most important question
is what happens with the grand jury
that's eventually going to hear the 10
criminal complaints
that have been made against watts and
the 22 civil complaints they're not
going to be resolved but they're not
nearly as troubling because you're not
going to go to jail over the outcome of
the 22 civil complaints the most
pressing question dan is
if the dolphins would trade for him
today and then want to put him on the
field on sunday against the falcons i
mean that that's extreme but they would
want to have him at practice they'd want
to have him ready to play in games what
will the league do we reported several
weeks back that the league has not made
any decision about paid leave for
deshaun watson because it doesn't have
to the texans already have him on paid
leave he's getting paid he's not playing
the league doesn't have to do anything
why make a decision about paid leave
when you don't have to but the moment
he'd be traded to a team that wants to
put him on the field that's when the
league would have to activate its own
process and make a decision do we put
him on paid leave or do we not and i
think it would be naive
to overlook the body blows that the
league has been taking over the
washington football team investigation
the email scandal and everything else
how does that factor into the broader pr
assessment of what do we do with desean
watson now that he's in a position where
he's playing with these charges pending
against him okay but how do you suspend
somebody who doesn't have criminal
charges pending
well
there's enough language
in the personal conduct policy to give
the nfl the discretion based upon what
they already know based upon the
investigation they've already done if
they want to come to the conclusion that
it's possible that desean watson may
have violated one or more of the terms
of the personal conduct policy they can
say you're on paid leave and the nfl
doesn't view that as punishment as wrong
as that is football players want to play
football but they don't view telling a
guy you get paid to not play as
punishment they view it as no big deal
well it is a big deal for guys who want
to play football and for the teams that
want them to play so why not suspend him
now though mike why like
because there's no reason to do it why
do it why why make a move why create a
news cycle here's what happens if they
would put him on paid leave now because
that's what this is suspension with pay
under the personal conduct policy you
create a headline you create an ap story
that ends up in every newspaper and on
every website we're talking about how's
the nfl justify
putting
desean watson on the commissioner exempt
list when no charges have actually been
finalized against him but there's no
reason to do it there's no reason to do
it and i had someone from the league
office explain this to me why
make a step that could be a misstep when
you just don't have to do it the texans
are already paying him to not play
we reached out to the texans
and we said why isn't desean watson
playing
and and we said whose decision
no response
yeah
well he doesn't want to play for them
they don't want him to play and get
injured and diminish the trade value i
think at some point it was just decided
mutually this is where we are we're
going to pay you to not play we're going
to trade you and i think they've been
leading him to think it's coming it's
coming it's coming the question is
do they get it done before november two
or do they kick it over to next year
i think that
they run the risk if they don't trade
him by november
that he shows up and says i'm ready to
go let's go play some football now i
don't know that he's inclined to do that
but they run that risk because i think
they've been telling him we'll get this
done
and that window closes in 12 days
nobody wants touah like what happens to
tuatanga viloa if deshaun watson ends up
in miami
well if deshaun watson ends up on paid
leave you need to at least for the rest
of the season now he's got that rookie
wage scale salary and cap hit and it's
not as difficult as it would have been
10 15 years ago from a cap standpoint to
move him but yeah then you gotta have to
ask yourself where does he go and who's
going to give you anything of value for
a guy who
who is showing us one week at a time
that he's not going to be a franchise
quarterback that's what this all comes
back to they picked two of them over
justin herbert
and
you know the two of mafia is starting to
relent i think after the month that he
missed with the broken ribs and how he
played i mean
they lost the jaguars they're up 10
points they lost to the jaguars who
hadn't won a game in 20 straight i think
people are starting to realize two is
not going to be what the dolphins are
looking for which is basically their
next day in mourinho and they've been
trying to find him for more than 20
years a lot of revisionist history with
justin herbert
like he wasn't a sure thing
i i know but it's amazing to me dan and
and i don't get too deep into the weeds
pre-draft because we're trying to cover
the whole league and everything that's
happening but
you know you've met tua i've met tua
i just
tua is short and tua isn't built like a
russell wilson or a drew brees he's got
a slight build to him he had the injury
questions coming in
i don't see how anyone wouldn't have
decided to do an extra deep dive on
herbert
versus tua because herbert's got the
size he's got the physique and obviously
he's been the better pick and and i
think the dolphins just viewed it as a
no-brainer here's tua we want to the
other guy they wanted was joe burrow
they couldn't get the bengals to trade
out of number one there was never a
discussion about the dolphins wanting
justin herbert and it should have at
least been a discussion
yeah and i i go back to the draft and i
had a source who said you know
one thing you have to understand is how
do you assess an alabama quarterback
because he has first round draft picks
they get open you don't want to throw
them open
and mac jones dealt with this they don't
throw receivers open they're open you
get to the pros you must throw a
receiver open
and you know dwayne haskins had this at
ohio state
that's why it's hard sometimes when you
look at this it goes uh how how good is
that quarterback
um
justin herbert has the arm to throw a
receiver open and tua does not
and part of it too is you don't see
those skills on display until you get to
the next level and the challenge becomes
more difficult do you rise up to it one
of the knocks on deshaun watson coming
out of clemson too many interceptions
and good luck cutting down on the
interceptions when the window
for getting a guy
the football shrinks well you know what
happened to sean watson by necessity he
got more accurate at the next level so a
lot of it is you don't know what's going
to happen until they get there but the
warning signs were there with tua but
steven ross wanted tua and there was no
one in the organization with the ability
to push back on steven ross and now
steven ronce wants deshawn
and i feel like he's going to get him
unless somebody else swoops in and says
to the texans we'll give you what you
want and send to sean our way we're
talking to mike florio pro football talk
live co-host with chris sims the show
that precedes this on peacock
the baker mayfield situation is
interesting because
he's gonna i guess ian rappaport said
he's gonna need surgery on that shoulder
at the end of the year but he's gonna
try to play through this
have you do you have enough of a sample
size
where if you're the cleveland browns you
say okay that's our franchise
quarterback moving forward and we're
gonna pony up 40 million dollars a year
no absolutely not and i laughed in the
off season they asked brown's general
manager andrew berry whether or not the
jared goff and carson wentz contracts
become cautionary tales for the browns
and he said no i think he had to say no
you know the problem is baker is
headstrong he's a little prickly he he
he wants to take charge and he views
himself as being a great quarterback and
that confidence has served him well but
if you look at his press conference from
earlier this week when he basically
acted like it was his birthright to be
the quarterback of the browns and it's
up to him and no one else whether he's
going to play with this injured shoulder
i couldn't believe that he said that
because it's not up to him and at some
point he is sufficiently diminished
while he's trying to play with a harness
on and the shoulder that keeps popping
out popping back in
he's sufficiently diminished where it
makes more sense to go with the backup
in case kingdom has proven he can get it
done especially when working with kevin
stefanski they went to the nfc
championship together in minnesota four
years ago so with baker now the bigger
question is
what do you do and dan this is something
that kind of flickered for me yesterday
you look at the veteran quarterbacks out
there that are looking for a tom brady
scenario where they can go somewhere
where the team has everything but
me whether it's russell wilson whether
it's aaron rodgers
one of these veterans that is
dissatisfied with the current situation
wants to go to a place where the deck is
stacked in their favor to win
the browns become very attractive they'd
have to move on from baker but the
browns become attractive and russell
wilson by the way was born in ohio
wouldn't that be a story if russell was
and remember it was back in 2018
that there was some talk about the
seahawks trading wilson to the browns
for the first overall pick that became
baker mayfield so get ready for that
because i think that's going to be
coming in the off-season but i think
seattle would have taken josh allen
well you could hey look you could make
the argument that josh allen's the best
of that pack it's either him or lamar
jackson and i was just told that seattle
did so much homework on josh allen that
they were going to take josh allen if
they made that move their number one
pick they were taking josh allen five
quarterbacks taken in that first round
two of them clear cut
and the other three well look we know
josh rosen done sam darnold who knows
baker mayfield the only fair assessment
at this point is who knows
why would aaron rodgers leave the nfc
north when you you pencil in
four wins you got the bears and the
lions you got four wins and you'll take
one of the two games against minnesota
so you got five wins
guaranteed
why would he why would he want to leave
that
i
you know he laid out all of his concerns
when he showed up for training camp and
i don't think those concerns
automatically go away for a guy who's
his head strong as aaron rodgers
if there's a better opportunity out
there for him to add to his legacy these
guys want to add to their legacies you
know i say this all the time when
there's a kid who's like eight or nine
years old and he always has to win at
everything he does we're like that's a
distasteful quality jimmy let other let
the other kids have a turn let the other
kids win from time to time but when
they're adults and they're playing
football we worship that mindset where i
got to win at everything i got to win i
got to win i got to win i've got to win
it's not enough that i'm good and i
contribute to the cause i want to go to
a place where everything is lined up in
my favor to win and if there's another
opportunity like that out there for
aaron rodgers i mean he wanted to go to
the 49ers could you imagine how good the
49ers would be yeah if he was their
quarterback and not jimmy garoppolo or
trey lance so don't you think it comes
down to
you know maybe tom brady saying are you
going to stay with that bleep and he was
talking about
garoppolo in san francisco if they were
going to move on they've been trying to
move on
or maybe he was talking about trubisky
with chicago i don't know
tom brady wanted to play for the 49ers
and the 49ers said no thank you and i
think all this kind of strange
dysfunction we've seen from the 49ers
this year where they trade up from 12 to
3 and they want mac jones unless they
don't and they take trey lance and is he
going to start and what's up with jimmy
i think they have freaked themselves out
with torment because they could have had
patrick mahomes in 2017 it took solomon
thomas instead because they thought they
were getting kirk cousins the next year
and between
the draft and free agency they traded
for jimmy garoppolo and then they had
tom brady wanting to come home and play
for the team he rooted for growing up he
was at the catch game he wanted to come
back
and you know what did the 49ers see last
year in the super bowl mahomes and brady
and i think that freaked them out and
they're still trying to recover from
that and then aaron rodgers
you know i think aaron rodgers thought
maybe the rams are maybe the niners
that that's where he was i think that he
was told that
dan i think he was told that the packers
were going to trade him and at some
point between january and april they
changed their mind and i think that's
one of the reasons why this went to
defcon 5 or defcon 1. whatever the worst
one is i can never remember but that's
why one of the reasons why in late april
this blew up because i think he was led
to believe they were going to trade him
and then they eventually said sorry we
can't do it this year
the man who has no awards mike florio
none whatsoever football talk live well
you know
maybe one day maybe one day mike
i've now i i seek
and will accept no external
praise once you know you're not gonna
get it it's very easy to take a stand on
principle and say you don't want it it's
like the coach who takes himself out of
the running for the job that he knows
he's not gonna get i know that i will
never get a vote for example like on who
gets into the hall of fame so i take a
stand on principle that i don't want
[Laughter]
don't give it to me i don't want it
thank you you're not going to give it to
me see you damn that's mike florio pro
football talk and pro footballtalk.com